all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the power
rangers
shattered grid yes we are and this
is this is kind of cool i'm actually
really curious to see how you guys
respond
to this little bit of a story i don't
know if you guys will like it or not or
whatever but what we end up doing here
is basically picking up at rita's
lair right like rita's whole tower thing
and this initially kind of picks up with
goldar
now again goldar has just ridiculously
good development
in this story right i mean it's just
it's the way that kyle higgins does this
is absolutely awesome
but what do you have here is fenster
who's basically creating
these putties more or less that are
modeled after goldar which i'm actually
surprised that it took this long for him
to come up with the idea right because
more often than not whenever we saw the
putties they were just like these
general guys and they would they were
literally cannon fodder and they would
just go and face off against the rangers
and they gave us some really cool fight
scenes and they would get defeated and
that would basically be it but
what's happening here is fencers
creating putties that are modeled
after goldar which is a great concept
because goldar
alone is pretty powerful you create an
army of him
and he's gonna be it's gonna be nigh
indestructible and so you get this
kind of a little bit of back and forth
and then you have femster who basically
ends up leaving going to find you know
some resources that he needs and then
stumbles across something that catches
his attention and so before we get into
that we end up picking up with the tail
end
of the last video that we did right
where the video had ended and you
basically have
uh tommy and billy in this alternate
reality where
tommy the green ranger had conquered
everything and they're basically met by
the coinless now again the coinless are
basically the name given to this kind of
rebel faction that's facing off against
and trying to uh overthrow
the power of lord draken and one of
these actually turns out to be aisha who
you guys probably remember is one of the
newer generation of power rangers that
came
after mighty morphin power rangers which
is cool but you've also got zach here
and so what this establishes is that
even though there was
this kind of you know fall of the
rangers right this final battle that had
happened
not all the power rangers died and
instead some of them survived and that
now because they don't really have
access to the morphin grid anymore
they're fighting off as best they can or
at least
don't seem to have access to the
morphing grid they're basically leading
a rebel faction and fighting against
dracon as best they possibly
can now the reality of this and
rightfully so none of them really trust
tommy
right or they ord billy because they say
like well you know we're from an
alternate reality but rightfully so
they're kind of like i mean what stops
the possibility that you guys
are basically moles here spies that were
put here by lord draken himself
and so that kind of leads us to believe
it's probably happened in the past
for tommy this speaks for itself right
that it's literally tommy right i mean
like lord drakken is tommy like tommy
from an alternate reality so it
makes sense they're kind of like okay
why should we believe you are who you
claim to be
for billy this is a little bit different
but having them here at the end of the
day
saba appears to zach and it's just kind
of like look man like
i told you i would come back at a future
point in time with those individuals who
would save the world i'm here doing
exactly what i said i would and that
really seems to be enough for zach
and so ultimately he ends up taking them
in and then basically bringing them
directly into
at least what you can call a base of
operations it's ragtag more so than
anything else
and then of course you're also met by
the arrival of trini so not every single
power ranger died here which is a pretty
big deal right this is this is pretty
awesome
but there's also big differences for
example you have the situation where
billy is talking to trini and she's
starkly different from the the trini
that he knew right i mean
in the the main power rangers universe
if we can call it that trini and billy
are
really good friends right they share a
lot of of common interests and so far as
like technology and a little bit of of
nerdery going on there
here she doesn't seem to really want to
have anything to do with him at all but
there's actually a motivation behind
that now you do end up switching over to
uh to tommy right to lord drakken who's
kind of having a conversation with one
of his generals in the sense of like you
know the
everybody got away from her and all that
kind of stuff so she's immediately
stripped of her power and she's replaced
with a new one right so that's one of
the things like this guy is
pretty hardcore and for the most part
that's a problem
right that's that's a major issue when
it comes to how he runs his forces yes
it instills fear
but it also removes loyalty whenever
you're any kind of a ruler or anything
like that
you always have to make sure that the
people who are the most capable
are the ones who are the most loyal
because once you lose that loyalty
they're gone more so than that they can
be the means by which to topple you
right to overthrow you
and so stripping a person like that of
any real measure of power
and creating a potential enemy out of
her could actually lead to his downfall
now the other part of this is scorpina
right now one of the things to remember
scorpina basically vanished when when
they were facing off against
the black dragon in the main power
rangers universe and this is where she's
residing right she's basically stuck
inside this universe just trying to wait
for a way to get back but for the most
part it's one of these things where it's
she's just kind of there but there's not
really any love lost between the two
there doesn't really seem to be any
indication like she's falling for tommy
and she's like man you're hardcore
gung-ho way
i love a man like that it doesn't really
seem to be going in that way
instead like she's just like i hold
adherence to rita right in so long as
you maintain your promise to help rita
basically conquer earth in my timeline
then everything's gonna be okay
the implication seems to be if he fails
or if he shows even the slightest sign
of betrayal she'll try to kill him now
the reality is she can't it's one of the
things established
right off the bat that when she relates
to him is oliver he's like don't ever
call me that again
right so seemingly the power he has is
enough that he could easily
overcome her and two he doesn't really
have any kind of romantic interest in
her either right like she's just there
and he doesn't really care about her at
all right it's just kind of like
whatever but at the end of the day he's
kind of like
tracking the movements of this alternate
reality version of myself and this
alternate reality billy and they've
basically met up with the coin list
right tracking them using the morphin
grid i know exactly where they are so
seemingly we can take them all
out in one fell swoop and so what you
end up having is really kind of rumors
and everybody talking and so on and so
forth and that where bulk
is a member of the coinless skull seems
to have joined lord drakken and so as
they're overhearing this one of the guys
saying like words spreading like lord
drakken finally found the coin list
we're launching an attack against them
as fast as we possibly can right
as soon as we can and so what you do is
you switch over to billy who's really
just kind of exploring the area right
just kind of looking around and seeing
what else here
he comes across this sort of giant
library and then sees a picture that
says
in loving memory and it's a picture of
him so he immediately goes to visit
trini and then asks the question
how did i die right like what happened
that led to me dying and that really
seems to be the big standoff reason for
training
basically being so removed from billy
and seemingly wanting to have nothing to
do with him
because he's dead right and so kind of
opening yourself up in that way and
being like oh my god billy's back would
basically invite
disappointment because she knows he's
not from this universe and so it's only
a matter of time
before he goes away again and so being
able to keep that barrier up and keeping
him cut off emotionally keeps her from
experiencing what would by all standards
of measurements be the death
of billy again what she the only thing
she really divulges here the only thing
we really get
is that during the great battle when the
power rangers were facing off against
the forces of lord drakken that he saved
her life
and seemingly died in the process now of
course at that point you end up
switching over to the story of zack who
really kind of gives this bit of a
revelation here
and saying that he was supposed to die
right like he was supposed to be killed
he said that lord dracon was picking
them off one by one he lasted as long as
he possibly could but it wasn't enough
and that he said he would he wouldn't go
down without a fight but seemingly
saba appeared out of nowhere really just
seemed to appear and then in turn
told zach like i will return at a future
point in time with those who will save
the world right now remember
saba as the sword of the white ranger
was the the fail-safe of zordon that
when the time came
where the rangers fell or if they ever
ended up falling that
saba would basically stay hidden it
would stay removed and it would stay
isolated
so that tommy and really as lord drakken
would never be able to get his hands on
him and fully come into
the totality of the white rangers power
if that ever were to happen he would be
nigh unstoppable right that's really
kind of how this is given to us now it's
kind of a funny thing because you end up
having
again kind of a continuation of this
conversation where tommy's kind of a
kind of astounded that after all these
years
that they still keep fighting and that
zach goes as far as to say like you know
it's been very very hard right we've
lost
a lot of really good people but what
choice do we have and that's true
right like literally the coin lists are
the only thing that stand between
uh lord drakken and what's left of the
earth and that was the nature of the
power rangers right to always continue
facing off
even in the face of the fact that like
death is imminent they always kept
facing off against them
and doing the absolute best they
possibly could and so that's why they
keep fighting here right it's strength
of character conviction that kind of a
thing and so bulk basically comes in and
then we end up learning that skull
is not actually working for lord drakken
instead he's really more of a mole than
anything else and he had passed
information to bulk saying they're
launching an attack
against the against their location
they're going to be doing it in any
any moment now and then ultimately it
ends up being too late right that you
basically have this massive attack
that's launched as you have bulk kind of
coming to them and saying this is when
it's going to happen
and so it really kind of seems to be or
at least going into a last-ditch effort
now the other thing that goes on here is
switching back to the main power rangers
universe
you pick up with like you know again
that version of zack and
and and those guys who are just kind of
training right zach fighting jason and
kind of staying on their guard right
kind of keeping their their capabilities
up while trini is trying to figure out
everything that's going on with this
black dragon zord and possibly trying to
find a way to get tommy and billy back
but more so than that what ends up
happening is that in the middle of all
this
they're met by the voice of alpha 5 and
that they kind of form this bit of a
plan
to basically get back to the command
center and find a way to to regain their
access to the morphin grid and that
alpha 5 can make it possible for that to
happen with them
right that alpha 5 is kind of an out of
commission but largely laying low
because alpha doesn't want to be
detected
by the forces of rita repulsa or any of
those guys
but it's exceedingly important here
because they can't maintain their access
to the green ranger grid
permanently and even if they could the
power of the green ranger is split among
the five of them which basically means
they're not
operating at their peak capacity it's
not until they reconnect to the morphin
grid that they can all become their
respective rangers
and operate at peak efficiency and
that's what alpha 5 is offering here who
wouldn't accept that right like and like
it would be it'd be ridiculous to do so
and so ultimately they're like okay like
we're getting our powers back
only for us to find out this is not
actually alpha five i mean it is but
it's not it's alpha five
being controlled by fenster a traps
being set by rita repulsa and by fenster
golar and all of them which is
genius that attracts being set to get
them back to the command center so this
army of goldars can descend upon all of
them and basically destroy what's left
of the power rangers man i gotta say
the power rangers comics are
ridiculously good i don't know why i
didn't cover them earlier i really don't
know why i haven't covered these earlier
you guys were screaming at me
for years to cover the power rangers rob
cover the power rangers cover shattered
grid like you guys have been probably
telling me this for like three years
we're finally getting around to it and i
got to be honest
i feel stupid for having never done it
before but that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace